este hospital de la ciudad alepo en el
norte de Siria está acostumbrado a
recibir heridos de guerra Pero esta vez
son los sobrevivientes del devastador
terremoto quienes ocupan sus salas de
urgencia
el número de personas heridas que han
llegado al hospital es de unas 350 y el
número de Muertos es de unas 70 personas
este hombre fue rescatado pero perdió a
13 miembros de su familia cuando su casa
se derrumbó
se nos derrumbó el edificio encima
éramos 16 y murieron 13 nos rescataron a
mi hermano mi sobrina de un año y medio
y a mí gracias a Dios
[Música]
rescatistas de Los cascos blancos tratan
de salvar la vida de agmet un niño
encontrado bajo los escombros
las operaciones de rescate en alepo y en
la vecina región de tlap dependen de los
organismos internacionales como Los
cascos blancos debido a la ausencia del
estado sirio y el control de diversos
grupos Rebeldes como el ejército libre
sirio y grupos fundamentalistas como el
frente al Muse
al otro lado de la frontera en Turquía
los cadáveres son reunidos en este
polideportivo
[Música]
mientras sigue la búsqueda contrarreloj
de personas con vida en las
edificaciones derrumbadas
escuchamos voces de repente gracias a la
excavadora las personas allí abajo
gritaron eran tres voces al mismo tiempo
las rescatamos Turquía epicentro el
terremoto en cabeza de la lista de
víctimas el presidente
visitó las zonas afectadas
todas las instituciones estatales están
trabajando en este momento
el primer día tuvimos algunos problemas
pero ayer y hoy la situación se ha
controlada
ciudadanos han alertado que los
organismos de rescate están desbordados
equipos médicos y de búsqueda
internacionales están ayudando en
terreno